[Music]
this all started with a promise that
we'd leave the big city and build a life
in perfect harmony with nature like a
traditional farm from the past here we
are
apricot laying farms Molly and John are
very happy about this what do you think
of this Tod this is what we're fighting
our version of a farm would be different
plants wildlife livestock all working
together here they are and when the pig
and mr. Griese the rooster friends for
life we wanted to believe that
everything had a purpose
we had our plan
[Music]
and nature had hers this feels
overwhelming but even the past have a
role to play and these are the
opportunities that fuel our farm they
told us we were crazy and sometimes they
were right we're starting to face new
problems we're down
we just don't have answers for no
our land reawaken this is a large
chicken egg
we saw things
that we had never seen before
[Music]
have you washed your hands ja the
hardships we face make the dream itself
feel so much more alive
Oh John please be careful
[Music]
well I'm delighted to have you guys here
I love the movie I think it's a quite an
accomplishment it's such a beautiful
amazing story about so many subjects and
themes that are central to this show
from environmentalism to creativity to
balance to overcoming obstacles like
it's all packed into this really finely
honed and really fantastic story so
first of all congratulations it's quite
an achievement thank you
I don't know what's what is more of an
achievement the movie or the farm
probably you would say the farm but I
think they're both you know quite up
there how do you think about it it's now
you've had some perspective it came out
in May and it's been a little it's been
a minute yeah I mean the film was
predominantly carried by John and so
you'd have to say which was harder
because for me definitely the time of
that John was crafting the film was a
difficult time because we had still the
full the full breadth of the farm and
that yeah the fact that we're still
married is probably the two year old oh
yeah yes so but I would you know so for
me the the farm was something that I was
more on the inside of but for you which
was which was harder I can't I can't
even pick I mean I think any mall was I
think that the the the meaning of behind
the pain that we were feeling was driven
by the farm more than anything else the
farm is like the the farm is the child
you're raising that you'll do anything
for mm-hm you know and I think that's
probably the greatest counting
achievement well the movie Chronicles
basically an eight-year period from like
2011 to protis entually present but from
what I understand you didn't actually
make the decision although you'd been
documenting everything all along you
didn't actually make the decision to
move forward with a with a full fledged
documentary until you were at like year
five right right yeah it was
I never wanted to admit it to anyone
else or to myself because I wasn't even
sure if the farm was gonna work and nor
did I want to get trapped in this idea
of making a story about you know a
husband and wife team sort of
fish-out-of-water story that I feel like
had been told of people moving from the
big city to I wanted to tell like a
deeper story about nature and this
interconnectedness and these mutualistic
relationships but I didn't know as a
storyteller really who the players were
but by year five became very evident
which you know which animals which
elements of biodiversity were actually
balancing our farm against these
epidemics of pests and disease and then
I was like wow I've actually
inadvertently been shooting a lot of
these Keystone players that's the story
I want to tell and I spent the next
three years really really focused on
making it as cinematic as possible so
that it was worthy of you know of a film
mm-hmm and there's this moment where you
have this realization that you're
actually one of the antagonists Yeah
right I didn't realize that until a
couple edits in telling the film during
the editing process and a singer and
didn't include my skepticism as ever
you're talking about yeah yeah and I
realized I thought you were all there I
thought it was yes I was so excited to
go to present this film where I was like
this great idea this this idealist like
my wife and who was so optimistic and
the truth is is that I was us you know
both but I was also very skeptic and
scared and so it's constant questioning
whether or not I was gonna be let down
and be told at some point that Santa
isn't real yeah you know I put that in
the film the hero I mean who do you
think is the hero in the movie is it
nature is its soil I mean there's a
there's a there's a beautiful you know
humility to the whole thing and this
theme of of arriving at this place where
you realize like you're you can't you
can't conquer this thing you have to
collaborate with it you have to like be
more in the allowing and kind of
gracefully dance around its edges rather
than trying to kind of harness it and
and force it to succumb to your will you
said it I think the for me personally I
think the hero is
our humility within the admission of our
vulnerability and need for nature mmm I
think that was the part that was hardest
to learn and then nature can become a
hero if you're willing to connect with
it in that vulnerable way yeah and you
know where I'm from on the Eastern Shore
of Maryland you're kind of shamed out of
that whole idea by being called a you
know hippie or a tree hugger so you
don't get to go deep but yeah that's my
personal what sure what do you think um
as far as the hero well if I just look
at it for just flatly and think I'm
watching a film of what excites me I
mean you really do all of the characters
of nature or what you celebrate and come
through and pull it off and so I would
definitely say from the coyote to the
Ducks I'm him at the moment when the
Ducks unfold out of their coop and you
see what their purpose is you want to
cheer yeah I did and I got to just watch
it because I wasn't editing it so I had
that experience of just wanting to cheer
so I would definitely say that yeah
characters we're entering a phase of
regeneration
just simply fun
[Music]
intermixed among our animals the
delicate wildlife is returning to our
land
the farm is becoming a habitat for them
too
[Music]
[Applause]
most I mean this is fundamentally I mean
it's entertainment it's educational
it is an environmental documentary I
think it's fair to characterize it in
that way but most environmental
documentaries are very educational
there's a lot of talking heads there's a
lot of charts and statistics and
research cited and expert testimony and
the like and you made a very conscious
decision to not do any of that so talk
me through that a little bit yeah that's
you know I grew up watching films about
nature and I think what I have noticed
and in most documentary a lot of times
what happens is a byproduct of sort of
taking a position as a storyteller as
you create a polarization around the
issue and with the environment what I
feel like the the missing the missing
element in the story of the ecosystem is
one where we're not acknowledging that
fear driving the conversation we're not
acknowledging the the destructive
pattern and response that both sides
have to fear one side gets mad and
blames the other and the other side
shuts down and what we need is a culture
of great curiosity not confrontation
mm-hmm because the missing element is
this is a society that is encouraging
innovation and that's what we've lost is
this innovative way in order to sort of
interact with the ecosystem and so I
wanted to make sure I told the story
that would open people up to the to the
to the element of change that I
experienced and that was I fell in love
with it so I became more curious about
it and so I was a sort of a book that
wendell berry wrote called it all turns
on a affection and and I think that that
that way into this conversation is so
important and so telling a story where
there's experts and pointing fingers and
assigning blame only does more to divide
us in a
where we need great innovation and
bipartisan yeah by him what do you think
Molly yeah I would agree definitely and
to kind of bounce off of what you were
saying about curiosity we were just
talking about that yesterday with
children that this generation because
there's so much screen time not that
screen time is a bad thing in and of
itself it might be yeah but that it
limits that ability to be curious
because you just have a video image in
your head of how to play so you act that
out rather than creating and having that
spark of inspiration so I do think that
the films the films curiosity can
stimulate that in us and that feels
naturally good to laughs yeah you fall
in love the process you appreciate all
the obstacles and and you know what it
actually takes to accomplish what you've
accomplished without fear mongering and
without you know playing the victim card
like like the planet is the victim and
we're bad and there's a lot of shaming
and a lot of you know sort of dystopian
an area of surrounding it rather you
fall in love with possibility and it's
very hopeful warm in regard yeah yeah
what I liked it I I spent time on the
website for the movie today and what I
didn't realize until this morning was
that you have like these curriculums for
kids you can download these programs
that basically you know take a classroom
classroom through an educational
experience you know as a microcosm of
what you guys have learned yeah mmm yeah
the impact campaign with the film
something we thought about before it
even released and you know really giving
a teachers a chance to be able to sort
of take some of the things that are
introduced ideas that are introduced and
turn them into lesson plans but you know
there's so much science behind every
frame of the film like you could there's
like a there's a couple of scenes like
between ants a Fitz and ladybugs and
it's like three seconds but there's
there's a whole sort of lesson that
creates a lens of understanding of how
the entire ecosystem works
just in that and so without getting too
heady in the details with the film you
know we've just that's that's all part
of that impact campaign afterwards yeah
did you have to resist the temptation oh
my god making the movie to not you know
dive into that I mean we were when I
when we when we did our visit the other
week I think I said to use something
along the lines of like well in the
movie like at all
you know you you you you're very
conscious of making sure that that
everything you say and everything that
you show is very grounded and relatable
but then in talking to you you were
going off on these crazy monologues I
was like this guy's a knowledgebase is
like 10,000 times what you would suspect
by watching the movie oh yeah yeah not
to say that you dumbed yourself down but
you are like trying to make sure that
that you know you were you were you
weren't trying to impress people with
how much you knew you were just trying
to create that like emotional and
intellectual connection with the work
yeah I felt there was a real it was it
was hard at times because I was yeah
here's what I learned though we for the
eight years in leading in doing this
farm we were touring people around the
farm occasionally we would do tours and
regardless of what they believed about
the environment or whether they you know
believe there was climate change was
related to human impact or not how they
felt about veganism vegetarianism or
animals there was this well this take
away that a lot of them would say to me
after the tour and it broke my heart but
it's it's it was a lesson and that was
they would say how so it's all it's all
connected and I'm like we've not been
meeting people where they are since the
beginning of this conversation and
that's the fundamental core message of
all of it right but what does that look
like no one's ever been able to show so
an audience in my opinion what
interdependent interconnectedness is we
talk about it we say words what is what
is this what is this thing and you
needed to give it players and actors and
in a way mythologize it with things they
can relate to so rather than pick like
Asian citrus psyllid as a character
I pick an aphid because people know what
at a fit is or rather than pick Tamarack
SIA which is you know sort of attacks
the Asian citrus psyllid I pick a
ladybug so it's a try I was trying to
discipline myself into using these key
stone players in nature that people
already know and now I've got the
Serengeti billet and I can go deeper and
get into the science and get it more
into the details but I needed to meet
people where they were and that's not to
say dumb it down but that's to really
just give people the chance to have it
visualized yeah yeah and
anthropomorphize the whole thing yeah I
mean the biggest anthropomorphize a
shinai mate was was when I tried to
claim that a rooster impregnated a pig I
apologize for that if you're creating a
lot of confusion if you're still
explaining if you're still explaining
that to your husband as to how that's
not possible and I will say kids never
ask me if that's possible it's usually
someone who is in their 40s or 50s yeah
yeah and we won't spoil it for people
that haven't seen the movie but remember
remember what we just said when you
watch it well let's I want to get into
the broader environmental discussion and
you know the themes of sustainability
and regenerative AG and and and all the
like but let's let's walk our way up to
that I mean this whole thing really
begins with you Molly
and a dog named Todd yeah let's let's
start at the beginning for people that
haven't seen the movie to kind of
contextualise everything sure I I was a
private chef before a farmer and the
reason why I got into cooking in the
first place was that I dealt with some
different health issues in my 20s and
started to make that connection about
how what you eat really affects how you
feel and a most fundamental level and
going deeper and deeper into that
brought me to a love of food and
culinary school and there I learned
about the fact that it wasn't actually
even the choices you're making in the
kitchen although you can soak and sprout
and ferment and do all of these things
to increase the nutrient capacity there
but it's actually the choices the farmer
makes because you have to start with
nutrient-dense food in the first place
so once I went there I started cooking
for clients from all of those different
perspectives and we started visiting
farms to find farmers who were cooking
in the way that were really treating
that top 10 to 12 inches of soil in the
regenerative way to then allow the
nutrition to be available to the plant
and once we found a few that were really
great in the region but we couldn't find
someone who was doing really great eggs
and we started to say what if we did
really great eggs and simultaneously our
dog was had severe separation anxiety
and we could not figure out what to do
with this barking dog so we thought that
would solve that problem yeah you're
living in a small I don't know like a
one-bedroom two-bedroom apartment in
Santa Monica and you essentially get
evicted because Todd won't stop barking
yes right yeah kind of accelerates this
whole thing right where when what was
the first night when when was the first
moment where you kind of looked at each
other and said like let's be farmers or
we talked about it for a long time and
we're telling everybody about it and
that was the thing we agreed on is that
we weren't gonna let people because they
would be like what do you guys know
about farming yeah why and we were like
let's not let people's like Seamus out
of this we didn't know that word back
then I'll be honest but we were like
let's just keep telling everybody and so
we would say it with a straight face and
then around the time that Todd got
evicted
we had also you know met someone who was
looking to invest in a farm believe it
or not of this type and knew that the
future of food was all about you know of
creating nutrient density right and
creating a regenerative ecological
impact and so it just was a weird thing
cuz we were only thinking we'll go get
five to ten acres somewhere and so that
all happened in this we were in
disbelief for weeks after we had this
conversation so this person that was
interested in backing a farm like this
what convinced that person that you guys
were good bet
I mean you coming into this with like no
experience right how did you tip that
scale and make this person believe like
you know we're the ones that you should
get behind we created a three-page
document
pictures don't laugh and we were like
and then we're gonna do this and we're
gonna do this and I don't know I mean he
really enacted with Molly on the food
part there was a really really deep
fundamental connection about the
importance of fats and the importance of
proper farming and all of these things
so from there it grew outward and it
really back then it was hard to find
people who were in that same space yeah
so I think we saw there was something
that was sparked there and the trust was
able to build from there hmm and then
you said about trying to find a farm to
buy or what did that look like
we had many arguments on the way yeah we
had a breakdown on the side of the 101
not a car breakdown but literally mental
however like what are we doing why are
we doing this as we're going to meet our
first real estate agent knew what you
were saying that no no that's oh I'm
sorry but it was clear that's always me
I'm trying to be the voice of reason
yeah but yeah we and then so we looked
at several farms and then landed this
one there's run real estate agent kept
telling us so you got to see this one
farm is like I've been trying to sell
this farm for 12 years and we're like
that does not sound like a good farm so
we kept ignoring this offer to go see
this place and we finally just said
let's just go see this farm the Terry's
talking about and we drive up to the
front gate and we like each other like
we have to make this happen it was like
when you walk into your house you know
you're gonna buy it was just that
feeling was overwhelming and we we
thought we thought bees we thought we
saw bees and we were so we didn't
realize how dead the soil was when we
couldn't see Pat it just looked like
Maryland back it's right I just we hit
it at a good time yeah yeah
spring rolling health 200 acres yeah
yeah and and when I visited I was amazed
at how I mean desertified soil aside
like how much of the structures that I
saw were there when you first visit it
because it's it's incredibly beautifully
and well-appointed it was a Nordic gate
from even from the gate like everything
about it is like
well done beautiful the wasn't
originally it was a lemon farm and they
were breeding like Thoroughbred
racehorses there so there was a whole
nother agenda with this with this place
the the fortune and unfortunate thing is
that had been sitting on the market for
so long and it was 2,000 you know coming
out of 2009 right right and foreclosed
on a couple yeah and and previous owner
was was really looking to get rid of it
so there was just a sort of converging
of sort of moments for us but it was the
structures on it made it appealing for
where it could go in 10-15 years but it
definitely made no difference to how
healthy the farm is going to be yeah
right so is it you know like I say it's
the old horse farm mmm abused pastures
and yeah fences so you jump on this
thing yeah I'm just like what's the
first day like I mean we didn't even say
like you're coming from a filmmaking
background yeah you worked on nature
documentaries and all kinds of different
you know sort of cinematic animal nature
based projects but you're not coming
from you know some kind of regenerative
farming background mother than growing
up on the Eastern Shore when the using
short yeah where I thought because I
live near chicken farms and drove
tractors on a couple of like corn farms
that I knew I knew farming but I didn't
know anything yeah yeah I don't know if
day one was like wow there's a lot of
avocados and I remember picking up a lot
off the ground going like that with like
that was going to end and I was like oh
wait we have a endless supply of
avocados but the idea of like what we
were really up against didn't come into
focus until we really got Alan involved
yeah but I would say there was this
feeling almost like it only happens a
couple times in life where you literally
feel so puzzly alive like a dream just
came true you know what you want
romantic this is your path yeah and I I
can even remember waking up the John I
couldn't be there yet we had so many
things that were still in irons in the
fire because we didn't know this was
gonna happen
and I wake up and I'm sitting there I'm
like oh my gosh this feels like a
fantasy almost like how the girl in
those silly me
finds out she's a princess it's like I
found out that I was a farmer oh good
and alive I remember the calla lilies
and the smells and still sometimes I'll
smell the smell in the farm and it
brings me back to that very first day
it's so good yeah well I mean you
maintain that level at least by
appearances from watching the movie you
maintain that level of enthusiasm pretty
much throughout which is kind of like I
look at it like you're this constant in
that regard that that John is always
measuring himself up against ya in the
sense of like you're holding that that
place of like hope and perhaps you know
some mix of idealism and naivete but
that's the strength that like John needs
to kind of keep moving forward yes
affair very fair enough and I think you
know in so many ways John I I remember
meeting John for the very first time and
it was like when my life started you
know it's like I needed his grounding to
deepen that nature that is me and
without him I was in culinary school so
I had to be away from him for a period
of time and I was up there and I can get
so just like into what I'm doing that
that's all I do you know I'll just I was
up there I was learning about food I do
food on the weekend all the time and one
day I was like man I've lost my Sparkle
or something something's missing
I was looking out the window and I
remember thinking oh my sparkle is John
like that's his something about the
energy that he brings to my space makes
it come alive so yes there's idealism
and a lot of naivety but his deepening
makes me deep right yeah yeah you're and
complement each other in that way all
right well there's that really fun
montage early in the movie where you're
like we're gonna make a bit of cartoon I
just didn't have a chance
from that I just take like you know an
optimistic enthusiasm yeah and perhaps
you know some level of idealism so you
go into this whole thing with that
idealistic streak we're gonna
you this differently we're not gonna use
pesticides we're not gonna use chemicals
we're gonna we're gonna do this strictly
in adherence with regenerative
principles like what was the mission
statement and you know what was it like
to try to hold that line as you know
obstacles started getting thrown in your
direction
yes started with yeah that was I think
that because of the food there was I as
for as idealistic as I can be I can also
be extremely stubborn and in that sense
I did know where I wanted us to head I
knew so when we had all of these older
farmers telling us that we can't do what
we're doing or trying to like tone it
down a little bit or whatever none of
that
felt right so the compass was locked
from the beginning and that's so helpful
in any vision you know that you know
from a seed you're not going to change
from what your ideals are there and then
it gets complicated because we did have
the ability to move quickly and that
makes you have so much opportunity and
nature is so much opportunity and when
you open Pandora's box you're like in
the middle of that and then that's when
oh yeah how early on do you bring Alan
into it I mean he you know and this kind
of hero's journey this like Joseph
Campbell you know architecture he's
definitely like the Yoda right yeah yeah
yeah and he was he felt like that with a
buddy just like a lot more cursing yeah
she was like hey Jon this guy named Alan
York is coming today to give us some
advice are there any questions
he's like this world renowned expert in
traditional farming practices
and he shows up wearing all linen and
sandals but there was this emphatic
cadence to his speech that made him
sound believable this is devil weed by
the end of the day you will have hate
for this plant then you burn that stuff
man
as if it's a ritual my favorite plants
puncture weed what is that
just grab a home do you love it No hate
it
Molly thinks he's great Molly but his
goal for the farm sounds almost too good
to be true pretty soon after we got
there Molly scoured the Internet but
also got connected with through the demo
organization which is biodynamic
organization that there was this great
consultant named Alan York who'd done
all this work all over the world on
vineyards if we could you know convince
him to kind of like get involved with
this project cuz it wasn't a vineyard
and so it truly was like another like
hero's journey thing where he refuses
the call like three times he's like eyes
want nothing to do with this you don't
know what you're getting into you have
no idea how long it's gonna take you
know and Molly was her persistent
hummingbird self where she just kept
coming back with the same enthusiasm
Pearson I would have been like all of
these guys like you know grouch I don't
deal with this doesn't believe in us
let's find another way ya know and he
was he was amazing there was definitely
just this kindred nature I have so many
wonderful memories from the very
beginning all right mapping things out
we mapped all of block em out on this
big piece of paper we sat in the middle
of the block that had no trees it was
all dust and colored it with her drew it
out with crayons and came back in and
almost does it exercise colored the
whole thing in with different shades and
things and I can't find it I don't know
but there was so much with him that was
simple and I think that goes back to
what we were talking about with John
with filming
anytime something has got gone through
the whole process and come back to
simple it's like how you watch a figure
skater and you're like oh I can do that
because they make it look simple yeah
and he was there so he would leave us
every time he he left with an outline of
what he wanted from us and it was
something that we could do and I just
that was like the Bible for me I would
go step by step through it to make sure
we were on track and at that point we
had no we had some compass of our own
but not really the level of depth of
what he was talking about was for sure
over our head to a certain degree until
you experienced that but it was I him
feeding it to us and the way he did it's
like a guru who only gives you what you
know you can do yeah but it set us to
then finally find our own compass
through writing it out yeah I mean I I
think of him as coming in with these
core tenets which are basically like
biodiversity is king and you know soil
is everything right I mean it kind of
just stills down to that and then he
throws ease you know obscure sort of Zen
Cohen asked like sort of statements at
you that confound you but he is kind of
that high-water mark that you're trying
to like live up to the standard that he
said and it's a thing that is that is
perhaps simple but also very much not
easy oh my god I mean it's the it
becomes like the ultimate whack-a-mole
situation but not at first you know and
one other thing that he did that like
spoke to me is a filmmaker because there
and I see it with you you have a great
aesthetic and I see that that must
motivate you and inspire you and I think
Alan always would always say regardless
of the science of what we talk about the
most important thing is that we make it
beautiful because the beauty is what is
going to encourage you don't want to be
here and look as deeply as you need to
look into this to find these solutions
you need to create beauty that
cultivation is full of endless
possibility and I'm like I can get down
with that yeah and and that was
something that made it fun while trying
to build
essentially this immune system that was
the science in the soil and Alan was
never shy about making that as important
as anything else that we were to do
right and I can remember in the early
days of Alan John and Alan would be down
on the ground digging in the soil
looking at things and I'm looking at the
to-do list like guys we gotta go we have
all this stuff to get done but it was in
everything in that moment with her yeah
actually everything and that was and
that goes back to John being my dad you
would say was there digging in the dirt
going deeper and figuring it all figure
out everything we needed to really go
where we were going all I would say
don't ask Alan so many questions about
soil today I'm like just like yeah but
then we talked about the soil day long I
probably go well I want to get into the
soil but before we do that I think it
would be prudent to get clarity on what
it means to be a regenerative farm and
what the differences are between
regenerative principles versus an
organic farm versus a biodynamic farm
versus a conventional farm can you kind
of break that down I think I can break
down three of those I think by the Nemec
and regenerative kind of be the same in
a way but so in like an industrialized
mono crop farm it's all about trying to
grow high-value volume product for as
cheaply as possible without any type of
reverence for the nutrient density of
the food and the health of the soil so
you end up creating this extractive
method of farming that's just pulling
and robbing you know the regenerative
power of soil out in order to grow food
cheap but you get this you know lesser
tasting food that is lower in nutrient
density how much what is the difference
in new in nutritional density between
the produce that you grow versus a
conventionally grown you know avocado or
orange or peach or whatever well I mean
it's hard to sort of put a 1 quantifying
number but like our eggs have you know
three to five times the vitamin A
higher omega-3 omega-6 ratio higher
lutein so there is quantifiable nutrient
analysis that would change farm to farm
soil to soil and then those are all the
things that go into helping us fight you
know degenerative diseases right I'm not
sure if I answered the car it's also
challenging right now to research really
anything with regards to food because
one its conventional is pumping n P and
K and other another suite of nutrients
into the trees yeah and those so when
you test that's not where you're really
going to be able to see it as clearly of
what's different but what you can
certainly tell is that flavor comes from
that difference so when you eat an apple
from a farm that's focused on
regeneration it has a depth of flavor
that you can't get anywhere else we've
been sold this story that in order to
feed the planet and meet the demands of
an you know quickly rapidly exploding
global population that conventional
practices are the only way to get it
done that we need to avail ourselves of
the pesticides and sort of chemical
Laden fertilizers that are required to
mono crop at scale but the truth is
something different all together yeah so
that narrative requires first of all
that that we are taking and we're taking
for granted that this idea that we're
there's a food shortage globally is the
truth and there's not so that that's not
true there may be food supply issues for
certain countries but those are usually
politically related we throw away what
30 40 percent of the food in this
country is UK now food waste is is Matt
it's one of Paul Hawkens you know top
right contributors to climate change
absolutely the methane that goes from
that burns off just from you know
decomposing improperly decomposing food
and in with in garbage dumps is you know
a court of outweighs the sort of the
climate issue with cows that we have but
I think the the narratives around
economics
are also very short-sighted and that
like okay if we're looking for the
profitability of a farm that's gonna
transition to regenerative practices in
three years maybe there's an argument
but at the same time are we ignoring the
the dependency on the finite natural
resources for which we grow food feed a
nation create both biosecurity national
security and deal directly with the
public health issues related to food
like we are looking at this in
completely the short-sighted wrong way
we're you know we've we've desertified
what 1/3 are lost a third of our topsoil
in the last two hundred sixty years
deforested forty six percent of the
trees and we're ignoring our dependency
on healthy soil so these narratives
don't include the long game like right
here in Ventura County we're not going
to be growing food in Ventura County in
30 years there's no there's no there's
no water regeneration is not happening
and that we're not capturing what are
putting it back in the ground for future
farmers to grow with let alone all the
topsoil that's washing out to the ocean
every time we grow crops without using
cover crop so what is the economic
viability of a people who can't feed
their people and I I think that the
conversation has to change around
admitting to ourselves that we are
dependent upon the finite natural
resources that we have been
unconsciously allowing to be destroyed
yeah and it becomes a national security
issue absolutely yeah you know as I know
Germany posts the war I mean that was
one of the big issues they were cut off
from their food supply and um you know
China right now is realizing how
incredibly dependent they are on outside
food sources to where they're not
allowing any land to be developed
they're saving and all for agriculture
you know Ventura County's got an amazing
you know rich Valley for which to grow
food and 85% of it is shipped out of the
county and 60% is shipped out of the
country right what is the how do you
explain the difference between
regenerative farm
an organic farm so organic is the
organic requirement is that you can't
use synthetically derive you know
pesticides herbicides and you can't use
synthetically derived fertilisers so it
while it helps to not further destroy
biodiversity it doesn't take into
consideration soil health at a
fundamental level where you're really
truly regenerating it nor does it really
take into consideration of the habitat
restoration that needs to happen on
farms for biodiversity to thrive and
create an equilibrium so it's a step
it's kind of like the Prius you know
it's a step it's a middle
middle-of-the-road step it took us a
long time to accept organics the cool
thing about regeneration is that I think
it's much more visually understandable
for people because it really is now
you're creating a flywheel system that
is in-line and biologically mimicking
the planet's natural ecosystem creating
a system that is prioritizing soil as as
king the grand alchemy of all death back
into life making it those decaying plant
and animal matter making them available
for future life and once you get that
pump started you begin to realize the
regenerative effects of effects of
biodiversity and topsoil and how we have
all been able to live on this planet and
what makes it so different than Mars and
the moon you just got to work your ass
off for like a decade yeah well at least
in a farm that had been extractive Lee
farm for forty five years
yeah but there's you know there's some
spots in Maryland I know about that have
a you know an 8-year headstart on where
we are it's not like this everywhere and
everyone's tree is going to be different
and the length of time it's going to be
different yeah so you're new on the farm
you bring Alan in he's putting you to
work what are the what are the kind of
unforeseen you know things that start
get started start to get slung in your
direction like the problems that happen
yeah well mainly Alan was there during
the golden period of and I think
idealistic enthusiasm and excitement and
describe did he say he actually said
that just to set it up it gives the
first two three years you're gonna be so
full of excitement you'll think how
could anyone not ever take part in this
life then around year four and five
you're gonna see all these problems
doing me like all four you're gonna see
all these problems you're gonna be like
we have screwed up and you know we need
to turn around and go back because but I
promise you by your fire in step five
and a seven you're gonna see the return
of the biodiversity it's gonna help
fight those wars against these epidemics
and so we were here he passed away
you're - yeah so in the beginning it was
all about just ripping out crops putting
in culverts and you know building fences
it was barely about agriculture it felt
like it was more about infrastructure
yeah as soon as the cover crops started
you created the worst epidemics you know
from Gophers to pest issues we'll talk
about cover crops because I think we
give lip service to that but I'm not
sure people really understand what that
means and why it's so important well the
main goal the main problem with our
farmers that didn't have soil it had
dirt so is lifeless and plants build
soil right and they are essentially
photosynthesizing pumping you know a
liquefied version of carbonic sugars
into the soil feeding microorganisms
these microorganisms are these alchemy
tzer's turning death back into life like
turning death back into available
nutrients for future life so we had to
make sure there was no bare soil that
was rule number one with Allan no bare
soil ever that's a complete violation of
our standard so we were planning you
know mix of legumes and grasses not only
are they rebuilding the soil through
that process of feeding microorganisms
they're creating porosity so allowing
water and rain to seep in right they're
increasing biomass an organic matter
which helps to create a sponge-like
effect with soil like an interesting
anecdote is we increase soil organic
matter between our up to three percent
in the seven years a 1% increase in soil
organic matter per acre
has first of all requires 21 tons of
atmospheric carbon to be drawn down in
order to build that but it also has the
water holding capacity that 1% per acre
of about 16,000 500 to about 25,000
gallons of water in the top four inches
so you're holding swimming pools where I
water with every one of the increase so
yeah one of sorry to interrupt no one
that was one of the things that was
super impactful when we visited it's a
pretty stark contrast when you're kind
of up on a high hill and you can see the
surrounding farms and how different they
look to yours and you were talking about
how you know when the rains came we had
heavy rains this past winter that the
whatever topsoil existed on those
surrounding farms just got washed away
in our water table or whatever whereas
your farm was able to just hold all of
that water and create this amazing
aquifer yeah and like probably a sponge
like layer of that was kept in the top
12 inches and whatever it couldn't hold
went back into the ground deep into the
aquifer to recharge it so your your
building soil your sequestering water
and then your actually these plants that
we thought of as weeds but these weeds
and these grasses and legumes are
actually helping to surface and cycle
nutrients like person is a weed to
people and we look at it differently
it's when you have an acre of personal
and that's 400 pounds of potassium that
you have living on the top of your soil
and is that decays it's earth filters
down past root zones and gives plants
and access to potassium your crop plants
so you're building the fertility right
and then you're also creating habitat
for predator species of insects that are
fighting the pest species of insect
uh-huh so it took us three or four years
to see the ladybug population come back
to such a number that it could override
the ant population that was protecting
the aphid population right right and
that's like to say oh I'm just waiting
three years while this destruction
happens for nature to return is not a
conversation you can have with a lot of
people right it's a scary proposition
but it ecosystem response to these
issues takes a long time especially when
you don't have the habitats in place but
now the habitats and
you've got this cover crop it's part of
the habitat equation it's not the only
thing and so the next season when the
pest outbreak happens you've got
predators that are like oh damn I need
to have extra babies I see this time
we're gonna have more lay more eggs here
literally the ladybugs will lay their
eggs right in the middle of an aphid
population uh-huh and the ants and no
one's the wiser they're running around
trying to protect the aphids and they
have no idea that in a few you know
weeks there's gonna be this hatching
colony of ladybugs right in the middle
of their house yeah it's brilliant I
mean it becomes this this like almost
game of three-dimensional chess right
you're you're you're sort of lording
over this symphony and trying to figure
out how to conduct it and the minute you
kind of figure out a natural solution to
one of these problems it just creates
another problem and the human instinct
is to Clint like let's crush that
problem and and it will go away like
this very like dualistic sensibility
that the way to solve that problem is by
doing this without an appreciation for
the domino effect that that occurs and
it's a journey to understanding that
that you know the interconnectedness is
so much more profound than you can
imagine and the implications of
everything are almost impossible to
track because they're so they're so
profuse right so whether it's the
ladybugs or the aphids or the ants or
the bees or the the birds who are you
know now eating all the fruit and then
all the snails that come out like it's
just a constant learning curve of trying
to figure out how to like Corral all of
this and get it to work in harmony right
and and part of that is just patience
right and getting out of the way totally
and I think you know we are looking for
the right and wrong ways to navigate our
lives and to be able to identify right
this is right this is wrong I believe
this I believe that and we try to
oversimplify
this thing called life with these right
and wrong perspectives and what nature
teaches you is that it's all about
concept
and consequences are our the truth and
consequences are not always going to
happen in 30 minutes they may take 30
years to understand the decisions we
make and the consequences of those
requires great patience and observation
and humility to know that the answer may
come in a time that we are not
comfortable with yeah and so to begin to
realize that nature also does not have a
reason necessarily yes or no reason or a
right or wrong reason why it does
something it really truly just works off
this consequential sort of system of
events is to free yourself from having
to know what's right and wrong and just
be be very disciplined to possess the
skills I think to observe and
acknowledge when you've come to that
conclusion and and from there you can
say you've got some sort of information
to make the next decision with
[Music]
you will see things that you did not see
before and as I looked closer at those a
fit in the station x' the eggs of their
predator
[Music]
you just tapped into a power of nature
that you can ride without an
extraordinary amount of effort
[Music]
[Applause]
it's exactly the same thing as surfing
[Music]
[Applause]
a flywheel in motion you're establishing
this equilibrium
[Music]
complexity diversity all supporting and
enhancing each other you will see a web
of life having that humility and
investing in curiosity and observation
as fuel for innovation right like how
can we just stop and really pay
attention to what's going on here and
get you know as granular as possible and
as curious as possible and and that's
kind of that's the you know pardon the
pun like the fertilizer for finding the
way forward like the sustainable way
forward yeah and being surrounding
yourself in a community in a culture
that supports that and that and that's
the trick right that's that's what we've
got to get to because I think we're all
desperate fear out there with what's
happening even whether you believe in
man-made climate change or not it's it's
in deniable that we're all a little bit
like well that was a that hurricane was
a little stronger this year at windstorm
so he bent ten fires in the last month
yeah yeah like I don't know if me I
don't know if I'm just gonna say I don't
know if man created that but I know that
that doesn't feel right to me
so yeah we're we have to acknowledge
together that that is something that is
prescribing or signifying and imbalance
and there's a reason for the imbalance
that's what we should get curious about
we had an earthquake pretty big one
right like not too long ago biggest one
in like what twenty years my son was in
the living room and he was freaked out
and he was asking me a million questions
and I'm like telling what's gonna be
okay and I'm like you know what do you
know what earthquake is he's like no and
I'm like let's watch a little video and
let's learn what's happening immediately
thirty seconds later he was completely
calm he had been able to visualize what
was happening it answered enough
questions for him to sort of feel
connected to it and I think the things
we are afraid of we can no longer turn
away we must be curious and not
confrontational yeah in terms of
surrounding yourself with a supportive
community Molly what was it
what was the reaction of the surrounding
farms and farmers when you guys moved in
and started doing things a little bit
differently um you know I I'm it
probably could have been more aggressive
people would kind of leave us alone to a
certain degree but it definitely wasn't
we were doing something very different
and nobody understood what we were doing
and we you have to deal with that
feeling of a little bit not
embarrassment but you're just kind of on
the outside of the situation and you
really just have to pool the resources
from yourself and the community that you
find you know in other ways and it's a
challenging thing to go about that I
mean John and I have always spent
different times not with our people and
so you're sort of our an island and
that's not it's not ideal
you wanna everyone wants to live in a
community but now with the movie out and
all of that
yak you're like ooh it's celebrity like
has it changed I mean they must be
especially when their soil runs off in
the rain and yours doesn't well yeah
they have to be thinking well what is
this what are these guys onto like are
they are they are they demonstrating
that kind of curiosity now I think yeah
it got better a little bit more the
phone yeah Oh give him a little credit
but I think a lot of it was well you
can't feed the world with this way of
farming and I'm like well that's an
interesting I wasn't trying to feed the
world I was just trying to feed my
community and is that enough you know in
my head I'm thinking I didn't say that
cuz I was like oh well I guess you can't
feed the world she's right but they're
now after about six years they started
coming around and asking questions and
we never have like looked at the way our
neighbors grow as like that the pointing
fingers at them and saying that they're
wrong because they're responding to a
vote that we have all culturally
supported and that is like I just want
my food cheap and I want to have my
blueberries in the wrong time of year
and you know so they're just responding
just like Monsanto it's like really easy
to like point fingers I don't agree with
what Monsanto is doing but they are a
product of our own making so we never
really preached to our neighbors and our
neighbors now
are seeing the health of our plants and
realizing we're not having these certain
pest issues and they're like so tell me
about you know the the the Ducks and
tell me about this and that's great
because that's what we need we need that
open dialogue and that was before the
movie so I and get to give them credit
now after the movie they're probably
just like I don't know what they're
imagining but but I will say there has
been a transition of appreciation yeah
that's cool well let's talk about let's
talk about soil I want to dive deep into
that soil is everything and part of the
process of restoring this soil has a lot
to do with the composting and the
composting T and it's kind of an amazing
elaborate thing that you guys
constructed as part of this whole
journey so yeah I think so there's a
couple different ways we build soil one
is cover crop the other is straight
compost meaning like we'll bring in
everything from horse manure to the cow
manure on our farm to landscape scraps
and turn that back into sort of a soil
compost and then the third it's like the
top secret ingredient of our farm is
this vermicompost operation which is
essentially compost where worms are
doing the work of breaking down organic
matter and the cool thing about worms is
that they're inoculating that soil with
up to 48 different types of bacteria and
then from those castings that worm poop
we then brew a tea a compost tea which
increases the diversity in microbial
microbial count of the of the of the
brew and then we literally inject that
as a homeopathic sort of level of
injection at a small dose into the
irrigation water to put all these
warriors these microbes back out onto
the soil to go to work
you know creating that flywheel effect
of breaking down decaying matter so
there's like are three components to
sort of helping build an established
diverse you know microbial soil yeah we
have the opportunity
to put our hands in the worm compost and
right in then actually yeah I like it
smelled it smelled great it's no like
like really good coffee grounds or
something like that right some coffee
great I don't know what that was we do
best make we do we feed the worms coffee
because it keeps them working a little
bit not true not true anthropomorphic
size then you you take like it has a it
has a porous bottom to it this this sort
of carafe where you you're creating this
compost and you take like a couple
inches off the bottom right yeah once a
week and then you put that into this
kind of brewing machine that creates the
tea giant 500 gallon to tea brewer yeah
sorry if I over a simplified the steps
now but like cooking yeah yeah and yeah
exactly and then we it's a big old
Jacuzzi full of air
lots of aeration stones so we want to
create these aerobic conditions to avoid
a domination domination of the anaerobic
bacteria and that's for 24 hours that's
brewing and then it gets like I said
inject it into our irrigation system or
sprayed in a foliar way like on the
leaves because plants are like eight to
ten times more efficient in absorbing
nutrients through their leaves than
through their roots which is pretty
crazy right you have thought that yeah
and another thing it does is it
colonizes the leaf surface with a
diversity of bacteria that helps to
prevent these epidemic fungal or
bacterial outbreaks on the leaf so
you're creating competition by spraying
it right onto the leaf itself yeah right
yeah and it actually was really
difficult to get the vermicompost been
working properly it's an art and it
really is like making sourdough bread or
people that make kombucha or all of
these things and so it's it's doing the
same thing that we are doing with our
body by adding those fermented products
into our body that's that we're doing
that exact same thing with the land on a
bigger scale yeah soil is the gut lining
it yeah I'm just gonna say there's so
many parallels between the two it's like
this microcosm macrocosm thing with
in the way that you know we try to
buttress our own you know personal
immune systems it's it's it's basically
the same process of creating
biodiversity either in the gut flora or
in the soil which is the microbiome of
the farm or the planet thank you people
always ask like oh I don't know if I
could farm I don't know if I could do
what you guys do but anyone who's been
through a health crisis and has then
addressed their food choices as a way to
cure their health issue automatically
has a four dimensional understanding of
how soil works and I this has been
tested time and time again with interns
and apprentices that start on our farm
the ones that have been through a health
crisis begin to understand what we're
talking about when it comes to soil
within about 24 hours the ones that have
not been through that it takes weeks for
them to really understand what we're
talking about and that's what Molly
offered to me because she went on that
health journey and then when I changed
my food
I changed the way I thought it changed
the way I saw the world it changed the
way I felt and so I was convinced that
there was a connection to gut microbiome
and all of those things and then I'm
like oh the soil is the digestive tract
of though yeah yeah you were just
feeding and cooking for the land right
yeah yeah yeah that's cool well one of
the things that that Allan makes clear
early and often is that you need animals
doesn't quite know why right or you know
what that means or doesn't have terrible
yeah just like go get but he's like you
need you need them so let's talk let's
talk about the animals so the
relationship between ruminants
especially and soil is a mutualistic
relationship that is the basis for soils
real healthy diverse existence because
you know like the rumen of an animal it
like a like a cow or sheep they don't
actually eat grass they take the grass
and they drop it into the fermentation
tank that is their stomach there's four
chambers and essentially it's the
microorganisms inside that fermentation
tank that actually break down that grass
and release these volatile fatty ass
it's into the bloodstream of the animal
which is the food and then all the all
the while they're there ruins are
multiplying these these microorganisms
and then excess amounts of these
organisms come out with the poop and
land on the soil and those same
microorganisms go to work doing the same
thing on the gut lining of the of the
earth and so you know that relationship
is really really important and with and
you know obviously also too there you
know the manure of animals is how we
farm pre chemical you know period 75
what is almost hundred years ago and so
without animal input you are reliant
upon these synthetically derived
chemical fertilizers like ammonium
nitrate which is you know uses petroleum
vast amounts of petroleum to make so
yeah they're a big player and that also
when a cow like goes and bites a piece
of grass you know I've heard it's the
saliva but also it could be the tugging
method of as the cow bites that grass
the root response of that plant is oh
god I'm being pulled out and it shoots
the roots deeper mm-hmm and so as you
send your cattle through these fields
and through these orchards you're
creating this response like a stress
response that creates resiliency exactly
they're driving their roots deeper in
response and also they're just making
those nutrients in that grass leave more
readily more readily available to the
soil because it's been sort of pre
digested and pre broken-down to be fair
there are veganic farms right there are
people that are that are that have farms
that are strictly on vegan principles
that aren't using animals I don't know
the specifics of how they make that work
but do you know anything about how how
they function I don't but unless they're
you know at some point along the way
unless they're using is synthetically
derived ammonium nitrate which is
heavily petroleum-based reliant and then
they're using another form of vegetable
that is then using that ammonium nitrate
at some point to grow so I don't know
enough to
to comment on it but the complexity of
the soil system is only informed this
way through animal interaction right so
you've got cattle you have pigs you have
ducks you've got chickens what else one
other animal so you have you okay sheep
ducks chickens sheep guinea hens and
then Guardian dogs uh-huh I don't think
I missed anything Carta four year old
kid that looks a lot like my dogs you
had a horse right so one thing I want to
talk about is the reaction that that I
got on social media after posting on
Facebook and Instagram that I had
visited the farm for the most part there
was a huge outpouring of love and
support you have a lot of fans of the
movie a lot of people seen the movie and
they were super excited about the fact
that we were getting together but there
was a very loud kind of vocal minority
of and like sort of a subset of the
vegan community who was very upset and
and that that upset is rooted in the
fact that not necessarily that you know
the animals on the farm I think but that
some of these animals are sold for
slaughter and food so I wanted to give I
want to talk about this I want to have a
mature you know kind of like dialogue
about your reaction to that and I'd like
to share a few thoughts as well
I just really there's a lot of people to
listening they just went and turned the
volume up a little yeah it's funny like
I don't report drama on the show I've
actually got on my way to avoid it
yeah and there were a lot of people
actually who were who were kind of upset
that I haven't that I didn't respond
immediately to that yeah because I
wanted to do it in this context where
we're having an actual like grown-up
discussion about it yeah so there's a
lot well I think we should cover two
things we should definitely cover like
the health perspective but I think I
need to sort of set the stage just and
just say this first of all we do not
believe that there is any one singular
dietary agenda that is
right or wrong I think we need vegans we
need vegetarians and we need meat-eaters
but here's the thing that I can say for
both Molly and I we absolutely if we're
gonna be eating animals you we cannot
allow food animal meat to be raised in
this cheap and inhumane way period end
of story the reverence is tipped way far
away from where it should be for the
sacrifice made we can get into the other
stuff you know as we go deeper but I
think first and foremost that's how we
feel and in no way are we trying to
convert people who are vegans into being
meat eaters in fact we have a lot of
vegans who work on our farm yeah so I'll
just sort of set the stage with yeah I
think you say and like you I think you
told me gene Baur visited the farm as
well yeah Gina who does farm saying I'm
Sanctuary because he was he after after
seeing the movie he goes wow I'm really
interested to understand soil because I
don't think I really understood the
relationship to the impermanence of life
and building healthy soil and we had
this incredible visit and he was really
great and gracious and I we shared with
him our experiences and I and I think
that's the way it should be I get very
nervous as does the ecosystem when any
one thing an idea an ideology you know
starts to take over without
understanding the consequences of that
ideology so I think it's something to be
learned from the ecosystem yeah
is it possible to and this is just I
don't know the answer to this but would
it be possible to you know find a place
like Farm Sanctuary where these animals
could then go afterwards or is selling
those animals for food like a critical
economic aspect that contributes to the
long-term viability of you being able to
continue to farm well if we okay if we
allow the the argument for animals the
especially ruminants involvement in
building healthy soil including ducks
and they're rich nitrogen poop that
they've taken and converted dead snails
to you know rich nitrogen poop to
fertilize trees if we allow that to be
something
that we all can at least agree needs to
happen if I have first of all I am a
meat-eater so I'm not denying that right
but I if I have 25 cows that I'm using
to help build soil and then at some
point all those cows become geriatric
and I'm now having to lift them up and
carry them over to the water trough
because they all end up with some form
of arthritis at some point now my days
are being taken with caring for a trim
you know this all these sick animals I'm
no longer in a sustainable model of
farming and I become overwhelmed
mentally and financially and my
reverence is to just let that animal die
a natural death and not do anything with
its body I can put it back into the soil
and let the onus of responsibility of
how that death was turned back into life
or I can acknowledge that part of living
is is is is being a part of the
impermanent process and taking that
animal's life at a time when I feel like
it no longer is able to live in a way
that is regenerative on our farm and
this is not going to it satisfy
everybody's argument about this stuff
but you know the hoarder situation from
which our dog came from is an example of
someone who was not letting go of some
of these very sick animals that she had
contained in her house 300 dogs and was
keeping them alive far beyond what was
humane for those animals and so there is
some issue here where if we don't
address the requirement for the
impermanence of life we're all in
trouble another point I want to make and
we talked about this you and I on the
farm is that again I'm just gonna I'm
gonna tell you your audience something
that not many farmers would ever admit
okay this happens on all farms if if if
you like eating avocados for a farmer to
grow avocados financially especially
biodynamically where we're enhancing the
ecosystem and helping nature we have to
grow at least twenty to forty acres of
avocado and we have to you know go sell
those directly to our market there are
to our consumer so here I am
farming 20 to 40 acres that's going to
require me to kill at least 35 to 40
thousand Gophers to protect those trees
hummingbirds accidentally when a
spraying non synthetically derived
organic spray accidentally killing bees
accidentally killing ladybugs and
intentionally killing ground squirrels
so there are you know fifty to a hundred
thousand deaths that happen just to grow
avocados and my point is is that none of
us are getting out of this without blood
on our hands it's just at what point and
how connected were you to the process
but that doesn't excuse you from the
reverence and the responsibility for
life
yeah I think there's a misplaced
delusion that pervades a certain segment
of the vegan community who have kind of
tricked themselves into believing that
because they're not eating animals that
they're they've opted out completely
from this cycle of life and harm and I
think that's just not the facts don't
don't bear that out and no matter who
you are and no matter how delicately you
dance on planet Earth we're all
contributing to harm in some way and I
think it speaks to this broader issue of
the complexity of all of this right
which is that's basically what the movie
is about it's this is incredibly complex
and dynamic and the minute you think you
have your your hands on it it will
surprise you in a new and different way
and you know my allegiance is only I
said this to you the other day is only
the truth and I'm always trying to check
dogma as much as I can and I consider
myself a compassionate vegan but I'm not
under the misapprehension that because I
only eat you know fruits and vegetables
and grains that that is not contributing
to you know in some negative way to work
towards you know these problems that
that we all care about and that we're
trying to to reverse and I think having
a mature you know perspective on that is
more beneficial than slinging arrows at
people and calling people names and I
just think you know people in glass
houses shouldn't throw stones and the
moment that you start to think that
you're better than another human being
or holier than now or stand from a place
of judgment is the minute that we lose
that ability to have empathy
and empathy is what we need right now
that is what the world is starving for
and if we want to see our way forward
together collectively we have to figure
out how to unite around our shared
principles to do what's you know in the
best interest for the preservation of
the planet and to do it in the most
compassionate way possible with an
appreciation for the challenges and
nuances and complexities of all of this
yeah really well that very well Somali
what do you think we just end the
podcast you know and it's it's tricky
and I will say I said this to you
earlier like it was painful to you know
see those comments because I've you know
I'm a member of that community and to
see them turn against me as if I
betrayed them was was upsetting to me
but it also made me think like where
what I do things differently what I have
not visited you would I'd not be having
that no it's like these are
conversations that I want to have and if
there's certain sector of the population
that isn't unhappy with it then that's
an issue that they're gonna have to deal
with good for you that there's a lot of
courage it doesn't I mean that we get
very occasionally called murders you
know and that's really hard Philippe
this you know regenerative
environmentally enhancing farming system
and it's thankless in a lot of ways but
you know it really does beg the question
of like where does life start for people
like does this start at the ant does it
start at the cow where does it start
because does it start at the bacterial
level because you're eating you know on
one Apple like a hundred billion
microorganisms when you eat that Apple
and those microorganisms are dying so
that you can ultimately digest that
Apple at some point I I think it's like
I hope for people to become really
curious and the vegans that have come
and and been very curious have walked
away I think with and maybe not entirely
changed I don't want to act like we've
changed anyone but they've walked away
with an appreciation for the complexity
of the thing we're all here on this
planet trying to understand cuz clearly
none of us understand it we don't know
how it works we don't know how to fully
replicate it it's hilarious to me that
we're trying to think about ways to
colonize Moon the Moon and Mars like
we're gonna get up there and like
re-engineer this be
beautiful life-giving thing that has
never received carryout not one day we
received a delivery from another planet
for the food that we were given
it is a venerable source of death and
life in a sort of infinity sort of
symbol and we need to take appreciation
for what that really means before we try
to you know / evangelize our own
ideology we should all be humble
students of this yeah I think that
what's what's interesting is you know
back to kind of John's point is that
we're all on board with with you know
terraforming Mars because it's sexy you
know it's like ooh that sounds cool
and yet we have so much difficulty
getting people behind the idea of
regenerating our soil which is doable
and right in front of us well we would
have to tip to in order to terraform
Mars we would have to kill a lot of
things in order to make that happen
because there's I mean we would have to
bring death to Mars in some way like
it's so much a part of the mean Matt
Damon grew the potatoes with his poop
that is that is the decomposition of
something that was eaten by him and then
you write so we it is hilarious right I
we talked on the hill at the farm when
you visited I said it's like going up to
Mars and the moon and trying to start it
all over it's like saying to your
parents who just gave you a car for free
you're like no thanks mom and dad I'm
gonna go build one out of stone and I've
never even figured out how to put oil
and the one that you gave me so I wonder
when they get there if they are not
gonna look back at this beautiful blue
and green marble and be like oh damn
maybe maybe that was maybe that was a
better a better place how many how many
regenerative forms are there right now
like in California or nationwide yeah I
actually I know from a biodynamic
perspective the biodome there's you know
a couple hundred I don't know the answer
to the regenerative farm but there are
there are a number and larger than ours
like thousands of acres you know I gave
Brown is one that I'm sure you've heard
talked about on this podcast will Harris
of
white oaks pastor there's a a number of
operations that have been doing this far
longer than Molly and I that we've
actually learned a great deal from and
reading their books and listening to
their YouTube videos and stuff yeah Joel
Salatin is probably the most Donner yeah
we started it with like listening to
Joel stuff and reading Joel's Joel's
books and you know borrowed from all of
these guys that's why we never really
beat the drum of like saying we're all
biodynamic you know 24/7 it's just a
method that we pull from but I don't
believe it's the only way nor do I
believe that you know holistic or
permaculture or anything is one right
one one right way to do it you should
borrow from them well I've had Zach dr.
Zach Busch on the podcast a bunch of
times who's very passionate about this
subject podcast favorite you know
regenerative farming farmers footprint
the work that he's doing with that
organization is incredible Ryland
Engelhard is coming up soon and he's got
kissed the ground like there are yes
there's a lot of innovation in the
nonprofit sector that's trying to raise
awareness and education and kind of
promote this way of of producing food
but what are like what are the barriers
that are out there right now that are
preventing more farmers from embracing
this way of doing things well from Oh
from young people or farmers that want
to actually acquire land I think there's
one barrier there and that just being
able to acquire the land to do this
that's in a huge barrier and the other
is that farmers that are in the midst of
deep financial you know dat because of
the loans that they've taken out in
order to grow high volume commodity
crops can't just do an about-face very
easily and would make you know argue
that point but it here's the thing if if
they if if you don't want to see it you
certainly can come up with a million
reasons why it's not possible what I
have seen personally in the last eight
years especially in the last year since
the films come out is the increasing
number of people who own land and are
looking for young farmers to partner
with to farm their land in the same day
that way that we're doing it I've also
crazy as it is like
these organizations these nonprofits
that are like land trust groups that go
in a choir land preserve it have
suddenly realized that the land that
they buy and preserve is better
preserved if put in the hands of a
regenerative farmer and so they're these
lands acquisitions being made by these
land Trust's and then they're finding
partnerships with regenerative farmers
to farm it because they realize that
regenerative AG is one of the best
methods of environmentalism and the
preservation and rebuilding of the
biodiversity of the land meant to be
protected so I see great hope in this
dynamic I think for anyone that's
looking to do this it's about talking
about it and telling people what you
want to do and eventually you will find
and be connected to those opportunities
you know that's that's sort of my best
assessment of the landscape what is the
what are the numbers in terms of carbon
and water sequestration on your farm so
like well from a numbers perspective on
like what we sequestered in water this
past year our allocation okay yes so
like one of the things we were told in
beginning is like oh well you guys are
gonna grow cover crop you're gonna take
a lot more water and get me drawn all
this water from Moorpark and we were
like oh man I don't know is that true
you know so we start the farm and within
a year and a half we're like everybody
else in California especially especially
Ventura County required to reduce our
water use by twenty five percent and we
get an allocation based for our farm
based on the crops that we grow not on
cover crop so basically the government
says this is how much water we're gonna
give you yeah this is the amount you're
allowed to use the number of acre feet
that you're allowed to use per year you
can yeah you get a penalty
I gotcha and also from us being like
wanting to be these eco regenerative
farmers it's like kind of like it would
be humiliating that we're overusing
water so we establish our cover crops
and within two years we never went
really over but within two or three
years after the 25 percent required
reduction we're ten to thirty five
percent under our water allocation every
single year and we grow more stuff than
any other farm you know acre
to acre comparison in terms of biomass
so in that time period we are using less
water right regenerating our aquifer so
we're actually giving back where other
farms that are not using cover crops are
allowing both topsoil soil nutrients and
water to rush out into the ocean right
and so here we have this system that is
regenerating itself there was one other
fact you has to question the carbon yea
the carbon thing so the cool thing is
that we've increased that soil organic
matter by three percent and a 1%
increase per acre of land of soil
organic matter requires the drawdown of
21 tons of atmospheric carbon so across
the farm it's three percent and in some
areas higher so just our contribution is
three percent right that three times 21
tons per acre of carbon that we've
pulled out of the atmosphere and I've
never even talked about that in the
phone because I didn't want the film to
be all of a sudden mischaracterized as
this environmental film that was purely
focused on the carbon issue which is the
elephant in the room but it is a
byproduct of regenerative farming right
that's amazing right yeah it's pretty
incredible so every once why I allow
ourselves to have a campfire and not
feel bad about how many young people do
you have working on the farm right now
well first yeah well like 50 of passed
oh wow yeah so we have a duplex house
where they stay we actually live on the
farm yeah yeah they it's either it
depends on how many woofers we have
based on how many apprentices based on
how many beds but all of those so you
start with our farm by coming in and
going through a three-month Wolford
program and it's really somewhat its
fully structured whereas some other
farms aren't and so they come and they
work five and a half days a week and
they're rotated through the different
departments they meet with one of the
twelve team leads that we have each
Wednesday to learn some aspect of the
farm in depth and it's you learn a lot
through that program from there we then
take on different apprentice
once they have a specialty and
oftentimes those apprentices end up
becoming full timers beyond that so we
have this wonderful avenue to find all
of these young minds and sometimes not
young I had different people that come
through that program it really works for
us did you get like a crazy increase in
the influx of resumes became one of our
our Director of Operations Trevor who
used to be a Wolfer and now he's like
the center of youth center spoke of the
wheel and has taken on the operations
position came into my office yesterday's
like so I'm gonna need some help going
through resumes now okay if we have
Sophie do the first round of interviews
cause like it's definitely use did the
film release in Germany or something
yeah yeah he says he goes okay there's
like these like this European influx
because there's like 50 emails today
right so that's cool and the cool thing
is we're able to be a bit more choosy in
terms of the qualification and we're not
looking for people who are experts
looking for people who have the right
perspective the right openness and
willingness and so I wanted to say like
you don't have to be an experienced
farmer to get the opportunity you just
have to really be the right fit for our
you know our organization it is cool
that there's so many young people who
are into this the most hope it's very
hopeful it really I gotta tell you like
they know more about me I'm when is 35
you started learning about stuff slowly
oh they're in their 20s and they're like
they know way more than we did they also
wholly care when I was in my twenties
like it's like that
I can't think of anything I would have
been less interested in right yeah if
somehow is like it's it's become cool
and they're curious and they have access
at their fingertips to the right
information and the wrong information
too sometimes but they've they've just
got it man and people say how are you
how are you guys even hopeful after all
that you know and I say the more
connected we've become to nature the
more vulnerably connected the more
hopeful I've become the opposite of what
I thought it's like I realized the
healing power that is innate within it
if we allow it to do its thing mm-hmm
and allow ourselves to be dependent on
it and then coupled with the influx of
young people and how interested they are
and how much reverence they show for it
I have way more hope about what's
happening on this planet than I did
eight years ago and I'm seeing the the
adopt people adopting regenerative
practices and understanding it at a much
wider sort of audience view than then
Organic has been able to sort of gather
since the 70s when it started I'm
watching in five years people suddenly
understand more about farming just from
the regenerative model that's much more
visual than the word organic we are at a
fever pitch pace towards a solutions
generation that is all about innovation
yeah that's very yeah and they also it
what they have that I think I didn't a
lesson I didn't know when I was younger
is that they know I see a problem and
now what are my steps that I can put
into action and when I was young I had a
situation where I was nine years old and
went to like a camp weekend thing with
school and the leader of whatever
session we were gonna do during the day
led us up into the mountains I can
remember the crystal clear blue day and
proceeded to tell us that if we didn't
change our ways that in 50 years but
there would be no or more earth to
inhabit
he's got more time on that prediction I
was terrified
i sat there I can remember I mean it was
like full-on panic attack for me I just
had like the hairs on Mike and my neck
were standing up I couldn't figure out
why nobody else was worried about it I
can remember literally the snack that my
mom picked me up from that place it was
like burn in my head and it for years
and years it proceeded the same way I
was terrified every time I heard of
climate change anything like that the
ozone layer was during that time I would
hear about that and get terrified
finally I was in culinary school in New
York City and it was the time
Inconvenient Truth came out and I was
walking around the city looking at all
these posters everywhere I could not get
away from it and finally I thought okay
Molly you're a grown woman go see this
movie and face whatever's scaring you so
I went and I
the theater by myself and watch this
movie and I got to the end and I thought
well that's a big problem it's a problem
but now what just like many any other
number of problems we have nuclear war
does a beautification anything and so
what can I do to apply and try to make
this better but somehow these young kids
they skipped all of those 20 years of me
floundering in fear and they just kind
of have gone right from I see a problem
and now I'm gonna work on a solution
well two things I mean first of all
you're definitely you've found your path
yeah confirm that yeah I think second to
that is that you know with our
generation there was no clear path you
know and that's very different now yeah
yeah that's thank you young people they
don't have to suffer that trauma they
might be angry because they've inherited
you know roblems that they didn't create
yeah but there's a there's an instinct
and a motivation and a desire that's
that's like you know coming from a very
beautiful heart centered place yes I
hope that you so I am hopeful okay no
it's like I think and I hope I didn't
say this already I hope you can edit it
out if I did I think there's there is
something to what's happening right now
we we were the generation I think that
was pursuing meaning and purpose and
there is like this there is this hint of
an acceptance around and this drive for
reconnection I think all of this this
the confrontational elements of what
we're doing and you know creating a side
and an idea and grouping up as a
community is really we're looking for
connection sometimes it polarizes us
from other people but ultimately the
reconnection conversation is a missing
part of the triangulation of a happy
filled life meaning purpose and
reconnection but the reconnection part
requires that vulnerability and I'm
seeing that in the young people that
come to our farm they're willing to be a
little bit more vulnerable and that's a
humility that you want to embrace yeah
well you didn't say that earlier in the
podcast so we're not editing but also
yeah I think I think we've never been
despite how connected we are digitally I
think
an epidemic of loneliness and
disconnection right now that's fomenting
a lot of the angst and and anger and
depression and kind of you know mental
lack of ease that people are suffering
from and you know what I see in your
example is that that connection begins
with connecting to our natural
environment in the most deep and
profound way and then it can extend to
you know our loved ones and our families
and our communities etc but you you
really need all of it I think in order
to be a fully integrated self actualized
human it's so true and honestly that's
what forced Molly and I you know that
the more we dependent upon the ecosystem
and were failing in that dependency the
more we had to depend on each other and
the cracks in our relationship were like
immediately exposed through that journey
and it made us face the fact that if we
were gonna keep it together we had to
figure out how to be vulnerable with
each other yeah so the land forced you
if it was its own like sort of therapist
yeah it was either gonna crack you apart
or he's gonna bring you close oh for
sure yeah we just arranged and had to
find support to figure out how to
navigate through layers of emotion I
mean when you're in when you're farming
you have to be face to face with grief
in a way that I had never experienced
before
and if you don't process that grief
you're not going anywhere and so that
that was a that was a big lesson but
it's honestly what the soil is it's the
processor they say about children the
best thing you can do for them is to
help create a good digestive enzyme
because that's what they're kind of are
all about him get dirty yeah well the
movie makes it look like essentially
every single night you're being woken up
at 3 o'clock in the morning because
there's some Cataclysm that needs
actually true yeah I mean it's for real
like it was terrible the first like five
or six years we had defenses weren't
right there was if there was a problem
to be had it was happening like I'm like
how there's no way we can continue to
so I don't interrupt but that part we
left a lot of that out or no na ever won
a farm then you have oh wow cuz I
thought that you were lucky there all
right you're just picking the moments
where you hung up but these are known it
could have been eight hours of just
complete sheer terror and all the
reasons not to do this but it's not all
so reflective of the real experience and
that is it has is more balanced and
beautiful to write it weirdly go
cyclically
is what I found in chaos is that even
all those years of chaos it's like oh no
here it comes and you'd be woken up and
woken up and woken up and then all of a
sudden you'd have like a week where you
could sleep through the night and you
like get yourself back and then all of a
sudden it comes again so if you you kind
of learn even and probably it's like
that in war or with children TSD from
that then it's going smooth you're just
waiting for some disease no it's
restoring you you have to breathe in the
restore yeah but also it's not like it's
better people they're always probably
better now it's much easier it's crazy
it's actually not I wouldn't say it's
easier or it's all better the way we
view problems yeah have completely
changed I'm not running around wasting
my energy on the fear of what that
problem indicates now because I've
experienced it to know that that's one
of those I can kind of let and live with
for a bit rather than spend all that
energy in the worry that turns into a
fight at night with your wife over
something else because all that stress
so we're spending less energy in this
state of fear it's all the same stuff we
just didn't know what to be scared of we
were like literally kids and then
walking into the haunted house for the
first time I'm just like scared
everything you know and I and I do think
there is something to that and that's
living through the rhythms of life in
one spot we traded an experience of
being able to travel around the world
and do all these really interesting
things for one that put us in one spot
to go far deeper than we ever expected
and you really do face all those
elements that constantly keep you awake
at night and you realize you can't live
with them you can't live in that state
of fear I want to put my filmed or cat
on for a minute and get into the the
technical aspects of what was demanded
of you to actually make this movie I
mean to refresh us this is an eight-year
period
you've Chronicle
from when you were living in Santa
Monica all the way through to the
present day I think you told me I have
like 800,000 clips or like couldn't zoom
right yeah exactly 90 terabytes of like
yeah footage and it's this I was
surprised when you told me that's that a
huge portion of the of the movie is shot
on an iPhone because you remember the
very cinematic high-speed photography of
the hummingbirds and the end in sight
and all that kind of stuff but those are
just kind of punctuation marks
it's an event yeah that the iPhone
footage sort of does band-aid with in
between scenes and even in shots because
it was what I would have at the ready or
another crew member would have to film
something that was happening in the
moment it's funny the one thing I did
teach my twenty-something year old farm
team was just not shoot in Instagram
mode like vertical but the shoot
horizontal so once I got that taken care
of I started actually having access to
more footage but um ya know it was there
was a lot of times where I was just like
something bad was happening and then I
was just like film it or something
beautiful was happening and I would just
have to remember that oh my gosh I
should just capture this cuz I may never
see it again so I was amassing all this
footage that the whole the whole time
but the way we got like the really cool
stuff was I would see these patterns
like there was a Cooper's Hawk that
every time I walk by her nest at the
time of year that she had you know
babies in there she would dive-bomb me
and I'm like I should probably shoot
that because that would be a great shot
to put in at the time that I'm trying to
explain that the Cooper's Hawk
dive-bombs starlings so I have these
perspectives that are impossible to get
unless you're tapping into a rhythm and
an occurrence that's already happening
uh-huh and then to simplify it like with
the greasy greasy and Emily MO
relationship which is a pig in a rooster
there's a scene in the movie where they
kind of go to sleep together they like
that down and there's this whole little
ritual thing they do and it's dance I
watched that 35 times you know as that
we go out to feed him and I'm like I
mean I should probably shoot that but
since they did it repetitively in the
same way I was able to predict how to
cover it
you know and so it made it look like I
was using like you know these like these
these like kids in animal suits you know
because of the the just the accuracy of
the of the shooting what is that
relationship between mr. Griese and Emma
yet that's just that's the heart of the
whole movie for me like mr. Griese I'm
all about him
I know yeah I mean as you should be I
mean when when you can land a beautiful
babe like Emma and you're only about a
pound to her 650 yeah that relationship
was one of mutualistic necessity greasy
would hide behind a 650-pound pig in
order to avoid being eaten by coyotes
every night and he was such a straggly
and ugly rooster that he was one that
was kicked out of the flock with the
rest of the birds and he found his way
into living with this pig but there was
a dance that had to be performed every
night in order for him to get access to
the house and so all I can say is man
love is real good and you can don't
judge it with the piglets now gone from
Emma's woods the farms ecosystem has
responded to this void in a rather
unexpected way
we call him greasy
[Music]
a beat-up and rejected rooster in need
of a safe home Alan told me once that
coexistence with land can't be forced
[Music]
it's more of a delicate patient dance
with no guarantees
[Music]
Allen claimed each year would get easier
and more predictable he called it the
rhythm of farming so you're sitting on
top of all of this footage like how do
you begin the process of trying to
identify a narrative well we went
through this to get geeky about it we
spent at least two years prior to the
year-and-a-half Edit process I spent two
years with three different assistant
editors literally stringing out every
sort of these fad cuts so we had like a
14-hour fat cut of just cows
I had a six-hour fat cut of just
hummingbirds and babies and then I had
like a nine-hour fat cut of everything
that involved greasy and Emma and I
gotta tell you I started this whole
release like that here's nine hours of
this put it up on it was like other than
that it would have been 90 hours I had
to narrow it down but Molly very kindly
like when I told her I'm I'm gonna make
this film she got me the Verner Hertzog
masterclass and I watched it and like I
don't know eight minutes in he's like
[Music]
yeah I'm just sorry for filmmakers who
think that 650 hours of footage is going
to make a great film I'm like oh my god
I've got 650 months I stopped I've never
finished it I stopped watching his
master class after that and then just
went back to work to getting the footage
well even though you didn't decide to
make a movie until you're in year five
you had the awareness or sensibility to
be documenting it all along so even if
you won't admit to the idea that you
were going to be making a movie you were
planning on making a movie yeah and I
never raised really you know the funding
for it until they you're you're five but
I will that's entirely true because in
the beginning I can remember Alan I mean
a lot of that very beginning footage is
only iPhone right because then Alan
would say you have got to document this
and John is like no I don't want to do
it I'm not
yeah like he really was over it he's
like man you're gonna regret this crap
you have no idea that's what this
is gonna turn into man it's
gonna look like the damn Garden of Eden
yeah I would say that constantly and I'm
just like ah just teach it he'll stare
steer you wrong no no right down to the
years of how he would feel like I'd like
to get too weird you're 10 yeah there
are certain little things we've now been
churned out and chosen to do different
with Alan and it's like almost like
you're you know your dad I hear his
voice in my head so when Alan passes
away why did you not go try to find
another version of Alan like you still
it seemed like you were still pretty
young and you're you know kind of
learning could be tried yeah we've tried
but only would find pieces of the puzzle
like we would bring in you know I've
talked to several really well-known
pastor consultants and I realized very
quickly that all three of them gave me
three different ways of doing something
and you can drive yourself nuts with you
know entering into the world of
consultants and you surely realized that
you it's ultimately up to you at the end
of the day so we did try to replace Alan
in a way but no one kind of like had his
you know his kind of mantra that
informed helped us inform our own
intuition about him saying driving it I
think that we were weirdly at this place
where if Alan had stayed alive it would
have been interesting to see what would
have happened because I can remember
struggles where we were starting to come
into our own and may have disagreed
about something and they would get a
little tense there and I think that if
he had stayed alive we either would have
had to have it out about certain things
and him let us have the freedom to do
what we need to do or else I don't know
that we would have parted ways but at
some point we kind of outgrew certain
elements of the knee we were even though
it did not feel at all like we were
ready to have our wings in a very
spiritual sense it feels like Alan's
exit was also came with unknowing that
it was the time that
we were gonna be fine yeah we just flew
I prefer that poetic interpretation like
there is there is this idea of like you
know the universe doesn't give you
anything that you're not ready to handle
even though it might have felt premature
it was sort of like okay time to put
your your big-girl big-boy pants on and
like that's for yourselves instead of
deferring to somebody else exactly yeah
we had conversations amidst the fights
at home where it was like you know what
this is not the time to hedge on
anything it's not going really truly the
whole saying go big or go home like we
can't we can't begin to be conservative
in our estimates of the need at this
point we must continue to go crazy here
yeah and that was like the best thing I
think we both did for each other is that
we maintain that level of commitment -
and you brought it up earlier not
putting a foot on either side of the
circle I learned that very relevant from
a holistic vet and he's like look you're
gonna continue to have these problems
because you keep straddling the line and
you just tell me when you're ready to be
you know in the when you're ready for
pre-emptive healthcare mmm like when we
can talk about that but I can't help you
with these problems that you're creating
by straddling both worlds there's a time
for antibiotics there's a time for those
things I'm not saying that but if you're
relying on that to cover your tracks and
the poor decisions you've made leading
up to that you learn nothing and we
decided that we weren't gonna and we had
people on the farm when we had massive
epidemics of morning-glory were like you
need to spray glyphosate we were they
were trying to convince us to spray
roundup and we took us five years to get
to this point for someone to say that
ultimately that ended that relationship
but we didn't have the solution
he had a solution yeah we just had a
will to sort of keep walking down that
path in order to find it I mean that
would have been a bridge too far like
every value would have gotten tossed out
the window
yeah decisions yeah it's the choice it's
like parenting that you have to make a
choice whether you're going to control
or whether you're going to kind of
unfold and if you unfold told me about
it yeah it's a whole lot more tricky you
know but ultimately you have an
established relationship that you
actually can pull into when the going
gets really really really tough and so
we made that choice and when you make
choice I mean all the horses are running
why when you're in the when you were in
the the thick of the film production
aspect of this how did you remain
mindful about how you balance the needs
of the film versus the needs of the farm
that was really hard on their on the
crew because I kind of sidestepped my
way into this project meaning where the
editing process started and that was a
year and a half that was so it was it
was challenging enough just to be
shooting while also farming but then
during the editing time I was real I was
in the bar and that's where we got a
film we've got like a whole production
house yeah we manage cool to horse horse
birthing stalls with you know literally
kicked dents like marks from homes being
bashed into the walls or all over the
walls but I would run I you know there'd
be an animal emergency event you know
like a vetting thing or calving thing
lambing thing and I would go out and I
would be in that and I would be covered
with you know all types of fluids and
come back and sit down in the Edit and
the editor Amy who is from suburbia
Marilyn's looking at me like oh we use
yes yeah we just are you good and I'm
like yeah yeah yeah so back to let's go
back to the first act and like just
trying to get it in where I could it was
really difficult it was hard on the crew
because I think you know their needs
didn't always you know maybe get Matt
and it slowed down like the what we were
doing on the farm but I knew that I am
like I got I just please stay with me on
this once we get this done you will see
what we've done we none of us have liked
to see it in 90 minutes what we've done
in eight years was overwhelming for us
and our team like our team was like I
had no idea what we were even working on
here like we they had an idea but like
not that not the level of transformation
that we were all part of I had probably
seen the film a hundred times by the
time we showed our crew and we rented
out a little theater to be able to show
them all and I sat in the back and about
halfway through I was like man I have
this huge headache what the heck is
going on and all of a sudden I realized
that I was holding back crying and I
cried the rest of the film and I'd seen
a hundred times
and it was just because to see it and
experience it with these people that we
had walked through that it was
unbelievably overwhelming and powerful
did you know that it was going to
connect with broad audiences or like
what was your sense of like how the
movie was gonna do I mean we could I
want to talk about Telluride at Sundance
and all that kind of stuff but even
prior to that like I knew I knew Jon's
abilities and I knew that he had never I
started to see the team that was coming
around him this time and I was seeing it
be different as far as this might
actually be something that people can
see
so they actually even get the chance to
see who John isn't John's like little
hoppy project yeah other things that
he's done that have had a certain level
of exposure but I could see that the
exposure might start to build bigger but
I would say that I truly always knew
that it was gonna be really really good
see this I need you no no but it's so
true she says this stuff to me and I'm
like what do you how do you know this
but here's what I did know I had this
feeling that it may not come out of the
box and just like blow the roof off of
the world in that sense that it might be
a slow build for it to go out and out
and out and out and that has been what's
happened but when we show it when
somebody gets in the theater they are
moved in a way that is just so
satisfying to see John be seen and that
way and that I mean obviously what we're
sharing is and we're sharing - I see -
in the Edit did you bring some wise
counsel in to help you you know sort of
objectively make decisions like how's
your Board of Advisors when it comes to
the creative aspect of how you crafted
this movie that's a great question well
Amy over back the editor who I've worked
with on three other films in the TV
series joy kekkon who was actually
involved early early days with David
Simon on breaking the very complicated
story of the wire and all the different
characters key word just so many
characters how is that gonna work right
so she was up brought on early on to
help me weave through stuff and I
brought in Mark Monroe is a really good
well-known documentary
writer consultant who's worked on tons
of different films I mean most notably
recently was like Icarus etc and Erica
Messer who was a executive producer from
the day who's been a childhood friend of
mine but also from the from day woman's
like you're gonna tell if you need to
tell this story and you need to make
sure that Todd starts it off this whole
story starts with your commitment to
Todd and the fact that you're not
willing to break that commitment and
that will drive you to this innovation
it's so true it's about keeping your
foot and your deal right so she's she's
a big showrunner right yes Criminal
Minds or whatever
yeah sure on television for like 50
years yes he's very young too um but yes
she's amazing and very experienced but
someone who I've relied on heavily and
then I brought in Sandra Keats around
your five-and-a-half who's a producer
worked in documentary for long enough to
know that she wanted to be out and I
heard of Sandra and I heard she was
quitting and I'm like oh wow she sounds
perfect though she's really into like
farming stuff and they're like yeah now
you're not gonna get her she's quitting
and she's gonna become a goat farmer and
I'm like hmm I might have something
perfect so she's like I'm driving to
Pacific Northwest I'm done but I'll stop
by the farm and I'm like accident yeah
and so she did and she didn't leave and
help me produce the last two and a half
years of the movie and a number a number
of other people but here's the thing I
did that I didn't do on any other
project to the extent that I did this
one and that was like I knew with this
project more than anything else I'd ever
done in my life that this was incredibly
special and that I had captured
something that had never been captured
before and that the only reason it
wouldn't work would be because I got in
my own way and I made the testing part
of this way more extensive testing it
with audiences then I had literally had
the physical mental Constitution to
handle like I showed it to so many just
really tough critics
audiences privately small groups of 15
and then multiple groups of like a
hundred or more and just took the
beating for months trying to figure out
where the common issues were what were
the big issues oh man I mean the debates
I can't even go there was more yeah
there was a little bit more in the
original film ended a little bit more on
the nose with this whole like idea of
sort of solidifying that the biggest
little farm is really a an example of a
microcosm of the larger planet and we
are probably in this all these people
listening to this podcast right now that
are alive we'll never know another
planet that is a farm in the entire
universe and that it is as special as
that and the point of the film is to is
to really say that so I pulled a lot of
that out then there's well the film says
it all the way to the end of the credits
you do back up to the earth I got the
earth yeah I did get the earth back in
but then I think also like questions
around like you know there should be
more data there should be more experts
there should be more really of a
polarizing commentary made on
Environment and climate and then there
was questions about well I think it
should be very few but we would get
people saying well I want to know more
about you and Molly and I can see that
in that compulsion to want to know more
but as soon as we open that can of worms
it becomes about John and Molly but I'm
telling the whole story of what was
happening behind closed doors if you
watch the film three times you see it
it's all there I'm just telling it
through the stories of these animal arcs
right and I didn't want to take to me
that was the easy road that was the eat
that would have been the easier thing to
do and so I think you know just staying
really disciplined and like I said if
there is something to be told I had it
like written in the Edit room if there
is a story to be told it must be told
through the eye
of the animal through the eyes of nature
that's what it actually said and that
was very difficult to make these
compelling human condition like sort of
statements you know through a lamb that
had been orphaned
yeah and how that related tamales in my
journey you know but those were more
interesting and compelling ways to say
it yeah I think it would have been
easier to make it about you guys and
that would have been compelling in its
own right a very different movie but you
make this you basically make this
ensemble piece where we're you know
you're featuring all these different
animals and and and really like you know
creating empathy for them and humanizing
them in a certain way yeah as all pieces
in this in this grand like interplay and
actually back to not to bring it up
again but back to like you know the the
the the conflict the ER that the assault
that you've received around you know the
vegan verse meat-eater debate I've done
more I think to advance the non
meat-eating movement in creating an
empathy and sensitivity for the these
are alive thinking beings so you know
say what you will but I I think in a lot
of ways people have actually questioned
how much meat they eat after seeing this
and I think that is a really good step
towards where the where we need to find
that this balance that we're all heading
for yeah well certainly you know you
have deep relationships with all of
these animals in a way that that you
know you're connected in a way that
almost nobody is so you get into
Telluride yeah that had to be exciting
it was amazing we we've found found out
the film hadn't even really been
finished and we were told that you know
just so you're clear like you know
accepting tell your I which is an
amazing amazing opportunity sort of a
tastemaker festival I don't accept a lot
of documentaries I think it I could have
this ROM I think it's like five yeah and
and they don't tell anyone who's in the
festival no you know whoa you literally
can't tell anyone until the day you show
up that you're in the
I told my mom which was a great risk she
uses Facebook ha ha ha ha ways that are
inappropriate ha ha ha ha
but so yeah that was really exciting and
we you know had never shown it to an
audience outside of these test groups
and I remember we show the film and I
have I see all these somewhat you know
jaded documentary filmmakers who I know
watching the movie and I'm like oh god
here it goes and lights come up and we
got swarmed in the lobby and like
everybody in the lobby is crying and I
was like oh I'm almost gonna cry Thema
I'm like I walked out I got to I went
out the exit door and I was just like
what the hell I'm not God it's like
worked yeah what and then uh Ryan Werner
who was the publicist at the time came
up to us and said you guys you got to
see this
and like I'm still processing the
experience and he goes look what a
variety just released the review of the
film and it was the most incredible
review that you could ever ask a critic
to write and it was just like we both
were like what the hell just happened
and you felt the shift where this thing
now is like thank you yeah I got it for
me yeah right cuz you're pushing these
things up these mountains all along and
that's how I feel like I've always
experienced as a filmmaker and you felt
the shift and I just saw so many
different you know individuals who'd
been seeing so many different stories be
affected so profoundly that they
couldn't control themselves and I was I
was just I mean what no such a amazing
thing they're in that screening Mark
Monroe was there and he was sitting next
to this like really older crusty guy
that was like kind of like a farmer guy
or something and he said that at the
very end the guy didn't just cross from
get tight shame that like face the whole
way through
mark was for sure that this guy did not
like the film and he gets to the end the
credits roll curtains go and he turns
over to marketing goes that was a good
goddamn fair
mark once he said that's as good as it's
gonna get and then you had was there was
it was there a bidding war right away no
they're not technically supposed to you
know you're not supposed to like accept
sales or bids on a film at that point
but there were definitely telluride yeah
tell your eye you're not supposed to be
selling and there's no paparazzi there's
none of those no red carpets it's very
low-key the distributors are there oh
they're there and we started having
loose conversations and hearing the
grumblings and and then they were like
well once you get out of the festival
you will really start that but then it
got into Toronto so we waited until
Toronto to have those conversation I see
and we were told all along the way that
each one of these festivals means that
you're not gonna get into the next big
festival you know and that was kind of
there was obviously all kept getting it
yeah like it's interesting that you were
at Sundance because I wouldn't you know
after being a tell you you know tell
your that's what I was told and I was
like all right Marc's like it'll never
happen Marc's done it a million times so
they could just it's very rare very rare
and I respect that and he's right
then it got into Toronto and then it got
into Berlin which shouldn't have
happened
festival and then it got into dock NYC
and we were like well there's no way
it's been in like and it was opening
night at dock NYC yeah and it was five
fests or four or five major festivals
and then we got into Sundance I'm like
Quentin the heck like no one at that
point then even like you know any jaded
individual left on my team was just like
oh I don't know what the hell this yeah
I'm done trying to be I'm done trying to
counter expectations you you do
something very interesting which is you
decide to go with neon for distribution
and and moving this kind of you know
down this theatrical road it would have
been very easy for you to sell the
Netflix yeah so walk me through like how
and why you made that decision the way
you did well I knew like I I knew from
the beginning and that this is you know
an audacious thing to always say is a
filmmaker we all want our films seen in
a theater and I felt a lot of shame and
being and beating that drum and saying
that that's where I wanted this film
scene it was made for that
it's an important enough subject that it
must be we must be shown in an
environment that gives it a classic sort
of stamp and it's best experienced at
that in in that sort of group
environment and I have nothing against
any of the streaming services I just
knew that I didn't want it to become get
lost and be viewed initially in that
form and I was told all the reasons in
the world why that was a bad idea I was
incredibly naive and I'm like well I've
been hearing that for eight years about
farming so I'm kind of immune to that
kind of advice anymore well the risk you
take is that you get a very short tail
like you know or at for a documentary to
perform at the box office is extremely
difficult and so these movies you know
are there for a week or two and then
they're gone and you've kind of lost
that opportunity to create media
intrigue around your movie and you know
it'll kind of eke its way into a
streaming service and then there you are
thinking well done was that just a big
ego thing exactly and it and it was it
didn't feel like Eagle to me ego to me
at the time it really felt like I wanted
it just to have that classic
presentation because I knew then it
would be treated seriously and for its
streaming life in its DVD life and that
kids would see it and that was really
ultimately my agenda is that it's made
for a very wide audience like a Pixar
film you know sort of does for animation
right it has that very wide audience but
I knew ultimately kids would be the
thing that would change the needle want
me to move the needle for this whole
conversation and so I went with with
neon because they came into the room
with their entire team Tom Quinn brought
everybody out like it was like seven or
eight of them and they were just really
enthusiastic they definitely got it they
saw the importance of its cinematic
release and I mean we had other pitches
we had other offers from other
distributors who wanted to do theatrical
so it wasn't like they were up against
just streamers but that was a easy
decision that's at a certain point
mm-hmm yeah it seems like they also had
a plan and
of the educational piece they were yeah
they knew that was important realizing
that you know this was gonna be perhaps
a you know longer kind of slower burn
yep yep they have there's you know Dan
O'Mara is there has experienced in that
space and they you know Tom and Tom
Quinn had been involved with you know
Food Inc and supersize me you know and
had a long history in food food fruit
related films but also films that sort
of did sort of create stir around
conversations and the environment
so I liked I liked that and they
understood the value that the impact was
really what was going to be and cool
thing as we raised a bunch of money in
the beginning before the film was even
released and sent ten thousand school
kids to go see the movie that's cool
yeah it's been it's been great and that
really helped I think everybody see the
power that this has over young people
because they're like oh it kids won't
sit still for it and I've watched you
know audiences is 650 kids and in middle
school just be like not say a word the
entire time and teachers like we can
never get them to shut their mouth you
know and I think that's that was really
cool
yeah my daughter who I brought to the
farm Jaya I mean I can't get her to walk
it watch a documentary to save her life
and I was like you're gonna watch this
movie because we're going to the farm
and this is our homeschooling
daddy-daughter experience so sit down I
had to like force her but it didn't take
very long before she was just like all
in like she just was all in and it was
like oh she loves animals and you know
it was you know it was a cool experience
for her so I get that that's amazing
so we're tiptoeing up against Oscar
season now like do you find yourselves
like fantasizing about that kind of
stuff or do you be like I can't think
about that or like that's too crazy or
you know where's your head with all of
that oh man I mean it's it's tricky like
it you know it is try say anything I'm
gonna jinx yeah I think dissonance
sounds so dis is s is so crazy already
I know exactly like it's like who I been
amazing I think if it were to be lucky
enough to be considered that would be
great that would be great for the
message it would be great for the
awareness on an international level by
the way the film's being really
in over 22 countries theatrically and
that number keeps going up which is
great even China Japan and Australia New
Zealand so like it's really great but
you know to have that nod for a for this
film would be great for that reason but
you know I can't say that our lives
would be better for it
but of course I think you know what I
was talking about at the beginning gonna
be that like pillar of life optimism I
don't play my really great films out
there yeah you don't understand the
dog-eat-dog world but I mean but we're
you know we're trying we're going around
and doing the thing that you do just you
know share I thought you know Academy
members and tis the season it's
important and I and I owe it to the film
to do it it's hard to put yourself out
there and be like please like me again
you know I thought like I avoided that
once I left filmmaking became a farmer
but I'm really intrigued by the idea of
continuing to make films now especially
around this space you know I had a good
experience I lost you know like it's
like childbirth right now after about
nine months you forget the pain you go
through and then you have another kid
yeah right exactly as a man so you'd
like are you already like ha the next
movie yeah I am now yeah we had to work
really hard on the farm to figure out
how to even get through the process of
sure this movie and so we now have a
structure that enables John to be
connected on the visionary level which
he I absolutely am completely reliant
upon him for while having our operations
not suffer so and storytelling I mean
how many people get to have a master
storyteller folded into their mix to be
able to tell the important root of what
you're doing so I think we'd be silly
not to have that be fully expressed in
whatever it should be yeah I mean that's
that's the Archimedes lever that can
really move the needle in terms of
awareness and education you know there's
what you're doing on the farm but how do
you scale that right you scale it down
your storytelling exact you man yeah you
know when I visited the farm you're also
like an incredible tour guide like you
took a ton of time with us and
you know showed us everything and
explained everything and I was like this
should just be you've got to find a way
to to provide more of that I mean I
don't know how much of that you do but
like this is that you know this is an
opportunity because of the notoriety and
kind of profile that you have as a
result of the movie to you know leverage
the farm beyond just what you're doing
in the soil to really you know educate
future generations of farmers and just
educate people in general so that they
could be better equipped to vote with
their choices and their dollars
absolutely I agree its ability to have a
storyteller there also enables us to
maintain the authenticity of what we do
because of that scaling piece if we
tried to scale and scale and scale and
scale scale and that was our focus we
would lose its we would lose some of
that connection
it's the lore that's been lost that's
what's that's what we don't have the
innovation from the past I don't have a
hundred and five year old farmer to talk
to and so this generations job is to
capture the stories and mythologize this
new lens of seeing yeah in a way that we
can pass on and they you know there's
nothing wrong with using I think
storytelling for that and I do feel a
burden of responsibility not to turn my
back on the opportunity I've been given
to convey that message yeah a big part
of the movie is you try to figure out
stuff on your own you have what Alan is
telling you and he's full of wisdom but
there are blind spots there as well and
you're kind of stumbling through this
and it occurred to me like why isn't
there basically like a rule book for
this that could have told you ahead of
time this is what's gonna happen here's
what you do and now you're in an
opportunity with the experience that you
that you've had to go to canonize this
and you know create a road map so that
other people can mimic what you've done
and kind of avoid some of the
difficulties that you had to weather
right and mimic to a degree because it's
all like very unique yeah it's gonna be
different right but like if the lenses
like being able to like define what the
words like mutualism even means or bio
mimicry or symbiosis like those are the
three lens we lens as we put on
in the wake of every decision and that
suddenly becomes your way of seeing
solutions that don't require an expert
it's crazy right now I just always say
that to me you don't always need an
expert for every problem you just need
to think about it in the context of
these three different things so yeah I
mean I think the storytelling enables a
visualization of what that filter looks
like yeah and that the teaching isn't so
basically what I get from that is that
the teaching isn't just about when this
happens here's what you do
it's about of way of thinking and about
a like a certain way of problem-solving
that requires you to think differently
exactly one size one way of parenting is
not a fit all approach each kid within
your family needs a different thing you
just need to have the filter of first I
love this kid I promise I love this kid
and then I start to see the
opportunities within that love for this
child to sort of connect with it yeah
but it's gonna be different from your
son or your daughter or one son to the
next son and the principals are also
kind of oddly and curiously applicable
to the workplace to how do you manage a
team of people and how do you like
there's all this sort of there's a
surrender aspect there's the allowing
there's the be curious you know all of
these things I think are powerful tools
that that that are that have
applications you know not just on a farm
but in our everyday lives I'm gonna say
one thing and I want to turn over to
Malik is the area that she's really I
think focused on the first eight years
for us was about building the immunology
of our land recreating an immune system
that could sort of buffer itself against
these epidemics and what we realized is
that it was incredibly reliant upon the
cohesive sort of cohesiveness of the
team think and the way that the team
viewed each other and viewed the goals
and that was not something Molly and I
were good at navigating and that's where
Molly has really stepped into this role
the next level of immunology for the
farm and that is you know how we how we
work our culture yeah yeah yeah that's
pretty much it it's just nice yeah you I
so we did
going through the film was really hard
on our team and so then as operations
had to come fully in my court I was able
to one look at the whole which is
something that as we were co-leading
that's you don't actually get that
opportunity as much and then just like
the coyote like you wrap your arms
around the whole thing and kind of find
the purpose in each person but then my
days are basically spent working with
the team to either help increase
assertiveness on one side or increase
empathy it's like each person is just
needing one or the other to be able to
find connection and communication
because ideally they're working as a
self-sustained ecosystem so they don't
need me if I'm most of my job is turning
them back on themselves either
individually to find their instincts for
the ones that are have challenges with
that or turn them together to each other
to trust each other to have the hard
conversations so it's I love that
because I'm getting the different
version of what we didn't know with the
soil and what I do raising his son and
what we do in our relationship and now
it's just applying that there but
ultimately they were going to work me
out of a job in the sense that I'm gonna
have more time to get my hands in the
dirt after I go through this process
because they won't need me I foresee a
Harvard Business School case study it's
really fun and it's just taken like you
know 20 years of therapy for myself for
the bargain price of a house yeah all
right we gotta land this plane but I
want to kind of end it with final
thoughts on what it is that you most
want people to take away from this movie
and your experience you're gonna go
first or last I feel like you need to go
last okay okay I'll take you out might
take them yeah but the pressure on crazy
I might just say ditto
no I'm just gonna keep it really simple
that for me this film is a love story
and it reflects the love of this farm
and this piece of nature that we've
experienced and so I would love if
people walk away inspired to begin to
create that connection in some very
small way for themselves that's it yeah
and I would say that no political or
religious side owns the conversation
around the planet I would say all of us
and Nate Lee know that we are dependent
upon the finite natural resources of
this life-giving blue marble floating
through space and allow yourselves to be
made fun of for desiring a vulnerable
reconnection back to nature and when
someone tries to bring up the ideas or
the conversation around economics or
practicality or logic stay focused on
that reconnection because I feel altima
what we're all starving from starts with
that reconnection to nature and then
from there to each other it's a
beautiful place to end at my friends
beautifully put I applaud you for your
commitment not just to the planet but to
educating people I do think this movie
is a remarkable achievement and it's
impacted so many people I know it's
going to continue to do that and also
for you know the courage and
vulnerability to share so much of
yourselves and to put so much of your
own personality and private lives into
you know into this story I think it
allows people to connect with it and see
themselves and reflect on you know our
own relationship to our environment and
our communities and I think it's really
cool so I'm really I'm really proud to
have had you guys here today and I'm
really really happy to talk to you and
share your message you're an incredible
human being and like it's just you're so
easy to speak with you should do this
for a living
yeah so the movie is going wide on Hulu
on November this week this week yeah so
it's in beginning of November
beginning on November all right this is
going up in mid to late November oh yeah
I don't know the date specifically so by
the time this is up it will be on Hulu
that's probably the easiest way for
people to see it right or it's on Amazon
Prime and all that kind of stuff too
yeah it's on Amazon it's on Google Play
all that stuff then could i that one
cool thing yeah the there's a live
orchestra scoring of the film that's
gonna happen at The Wiltern in LA on
December 4th which is cool so the actual
conductor who wrote the music is going
to be there scoring the film live two
picture while audiences get to watch it
at The Wiltern on December 4th that's
very cool I'm so excited about that and
the Jeff Beal whos the composer amazing
talented guy is putting this together so
if you haven't seen the movie great way
to see it yeah cool is it are there
still tickets available for there there
might be still tickets available yeah
that they're just I mean as we're
speaking today they're going on sale
this week cool well all find that link
and I'll put it up in the shoutouts so
if you're in doubt like I'll check that
out well hopefully you can make it out
and see right you guys peace
[Music]